what's up everyone welcome back to the
supper suite at tiff 2022 i've got the
team behind emily huge huge huge
congratulations on your film
thank you thank you i have a feeling
you're going to do this a lot frances
but i need to pose this first question
to start here for anybody out there who
does not know what emily is can you give
us a brief synopsis of your movie
uh
a young girl in the middle of nowhere uh
decides she's going to find out who she
is and she just happens to be emily
bronte nice you nailed that okay i made
that up on the spot i'm very impressed
right now so i was reading that you have
been working on this for something like
a decade so what would you say is the
biggest difference between what you
envisioned for the film 10 years ago
compared to how it turned out today
i guess um it was something i kept
returning to when i was working on other
gigs as an actor and i think just having
that time you have that kind of
uh time to kind of deepen the work i
guess and um
[Music]
but i i've already written my next thing
and i did not take a decade to write it
that's a little that's a little bit too
long
but yeah yeah i actually i frances and i
worked together about about that time
tell me i was writing it then
you you you told me you told me i'm
thinking about writing a
thing about emily bronte oh yeah
yeah we were teenagers then yeah
no mid-20s kindergarten was fun yeah
i don't know if this is story specific
but having taken so long and needed so
much time to write emily and then having
that next product just come right out of
you is there anything about the process
of writing or making this movie that you
think kind of like facilitates happening
yeah i mean i think i mean i've been on
sets like my whole life but there's
something different about being on that
side and there is a certain blindness
that you you just the only way you can
learn how to do it is to walk through it
and it's just great to know that i've
just learned so much and i've got a
whole bag of tools in terms of like my
next one things i won't have to think
about that you have to think about
really
is there a specific example you can
share
i guess editing editing something that
is so complicated and is such a mind f
that um
that that um
it's something that
you the only way to learn how to do it
is to do it and if that's your first
film that's how you learn to to edit
so um but yeah but fun really fun it's
about to blurt out you can drop f-bombs
but we're in the supper suite so maybe
not
emma for you i'm a big sex education fan
and i know it can be very important in
like a high pressure situation when
you're picking projects to fill the time
in between seasons so what are some of
your priorities in terms of what you go
out to pick but then also i'm really
curious because the things you have
picked are so incredibly different so
what is something consistent about all
those films that you need to see but
then also what is something about emily
that you know helped you scratch a
creative itch that you've never done on
any of your other projects and you need
right now
that's okay um
i'm gonna try and remember everything um
uh there isn't a list of requirements
necessary that i look for but what was
so great about emily is it felt it was
the right time for that kind of project
i was really excited about doing
working with a literary figure so to
speak um
and it just felt like there was a lot to
do there was a lot to get our teeth
stuck into you know what i mean it felt
like a complete thing there was a whole
range of
things to do and a palette of colors to
explore so it was really um yeah it felt
like a whole piece
to to to do so that was really exciting
and then yeah i've been very lucky to do
different
things but i but i it's uh it's yeah
it's always scripts if the you know same
with emily it's you read the script and
you have an you know an instinct about
it and you kind of just
follow that thus far you seem to know
the right pick the right scripts to pick
but also the right people to work with
that's right
not this guy girls
um ally i'll come to you next so i know
there there's a lot of like mystery and
the truth to the situation here but what
is something that you isolated as an
important thing to highlight in the
emily charlotte relationship that you
really wanted to make come through
oh
i suppose it's the the balance of
of kind of
their love for one another
but
also
well for for charlotte it was it there
was very much a sense of emily's emily
being this kind of rebel or this
difficult character or something
charlotte
found very difficult because she was
much more concerned
about how other people
saw her you know whereas emily just
didn't care like she was just fine with
being a weirdo
so so it was kind of that thing of being
able to balance the kind of love and
care and the protectiveness
with
the kind of judgment and
yeah
the judgement and the kind of
frustration so
there's a lot of things not one thing
sorry
it's important you feel all those things
coming through a complex relationship
i'll add to the sibling dynamic and i'll
go to you next amelia what do you think
it is about anne that
i guess put her in a good position to be
a mediator and understand her sister's
truths when they couldn't really do the
same thing for her or each other for
that matter
i mean i guess like being the youngest
sibling kind of
seeing how the other siblings have grown
up and have their dynamics and different
things that they bicker on or get on
with i guess she was kind of like
you know
very observant because you know in
looking up like researching stuff about
her i feel like she was very observant
and stuff like this so i tried to kind
of
take that on board when i was thinking
about how she would be the mediator and
like you know because charlotte and
emily's relationship's a bit like
well a little bit all over the place
um so yeah i think it was probably like
her way of trying to keep the peace in
the house and like you know keep
everyone loving one another and
you know just kind of just being a chill
girl really
i like that dynamic i feel like in uh or
at least in most movies we usually see
the the older sibling portrayed as like
the knowing one who kind of keeps
control i kind of like that perspective
on it it'll make me rethink how my
little sister looks on me
um for the whole cast because you just
brought up the research i know you all
did a lot of prep and actually you can
answer this too but you did a lot of
prep before jumping into filming but is
there anything you discovered about your
own character or this story while you
were on set in the moment working on a
scene that all the research in the world
never would have led you to
oh
i thought um
if you don't mind
i when we went to visit the parsonage
and we saw that you know there was like
the little e like sketched in on the
table did you guys see that and they
weren't sure if that was like emily that
did it or not but they were like i mean
maybe she did maybe she was a little bit
which i didn't yeah
yeah so and i didn't see anything to do
with that like when i was looking stuff
up before and that was quite fun like
fun little thing and when they were
telling us about how they used to circle
around the table
do you remember yeah
and they were like they'd like be
talking about their stories and
everything yeah yeah the cast got to go
to the real parsonage and kind of talk
to these amazing women who just know
everything about the brontes and just
walk it in the rooms and
yeah i think it was which was very
evocative i think yeah yeah anyone else
want to add something that was
discovered on set
well i mean i feel i feel like it's it's
a bit of an interesting one
for the character though i play because
he was a real person but but there's not
an awful lot about him
out in the world so even when we went to
the parsonage and we went
we went to his grave
um but there's very little known apart
from what francis has sort of included
in the story so
i felt
sort of
a a little bit as like an outsider in
the sort of prep i i got to with francis
sort of create
we had sort of quite a lot of freedom
really to sort of create and so much of
it was already on the page um
but yeah but so i
don't know if there's anything that that
it's a i guess i'm probably not the best
person to answer this question because
do you know what i mean there's like a
couple of blogs like i think when we did
the mask scene there were certain things
in that scene it's so good oh thank you
yeah
but there were certain things i think we
all felt like we'd all read it and we'd
kind of rehearsed it but then when we
actually did it i think we were like we
felt like oh there's something happening
here yeah yeah
that's the thing
you do so much research and you do all
the
the prep and then like you say it's kind
of you you only learn when you do the
thing so
all these surprises and intricacies come
out the floorboards in a way you know
what i mean so you suddenly get all
these oh i didn't even know that could
it happen so it's just nice to be
surprised yeah like when you put the
mask on
and we did some of those long takes
there was just something about that the
moment we all where i think we were all
kind of
surprised and we were like and that was
kind of early on in the shoot too in
terms of informing other things so eerie
it was very
i definitely found something about um
like with emily's charac
character but the person being such an
enigma and holding so much back
that feeling of like longing to get
close to her and wanting to get in i
didn't
know how much that would sort of like
mean to me like affect me so i think
that to me wasn't something i'd really
thought about but that longing to like
know your family like know your sister
and feeling like
you don't like you know that that
that was something i think came up in
the in the filming of it for me which is
really real i think sometimes
you know with siblings you think that
you're so intimate and you know each
other so well but in other ways they're
just total strangers to you and i think
it was very much like that for the real
brontes as well yeah but as you were
explaining that like i feel like i got a
really stressed look on my face because
i'm like do i really know myself
alvaro come your way now
what is this is like an impossible
question to answer but what is the key
to playing a character like him with
some consistency even when he has
everything he believes and turned on its
head
uh oh gosh i mean francis uh when we
were
in sort of a rehearsal sort of prep she
said the most genius thing she said
nothing bad's ever happened to him
up until the moment he comes so there
was something
kind of joyous about his sort of he
arrives and then it's the jumping off a
cliff that happens and this whole world
kind of comes crashing down
so that was
quite an amazing place to start just
with the knowing because i was sort of
coming in being like that but maybe she
was like that no nothing
this sort of
idyllic life um
and this is his this is his sort of uh
downfall this is so that was such an
interesting
i i guess sort of interesting place to
start but i'm also not religious i was
sort of raised not so
it was so interesting in the prep i
spoke to quite a few i mean you put me
in touch with a really like interesting
kind of spiritual guy and i was working
uh on this movie uh with shot an actor
called chapped arisa and his parents are
pastors and so i had these
sort of really interesting zooms with
them because i became quite fascinated
about
the idea of
safety that these people feel that it's
you know this this idea of feeling held
by the world and if that's compromise
then what does that then do to your
whole existence um so i don't know if
that answers your question perry but um
i mean i said it before there was no one
right answer
to that question i'll end with i have so
many more things i want to ask you guys
but one thing that i was reading about
in the press notes that fascinates me
because i don't think many actors get
the opportunity to work like this on a
film set is the idea of acting without
any marks
is there anything about the actor's
cinematographer relationship that you
all discovered working that way where
there's more like handheld and fluid
camera work that you might take on to a
future film
i love it yeah yeah i it was i didn't
feel stuck i feel like a lot of time
with marks or with lighting sometimes
you pre sometimes you go into a set and
everything is done for you and you just
need to stand in a certain place
here a lot of the time we kind of just
got to
feel it out and figure out where we
wanted to be and what we wanted to do
and
enough because we're using natural light
in a lot of it and we're outdoors a lot
you you get that freedom to just move
about and you're following the camera's
following you or you're following it
felt very
um
not to use the overused word organic but
it felt very organic you know i mean it
feels like it just it had that fluidity
to it a lot of the time even if you're
in a costume drama even if you're in
corsets i never felt uh
tense or stilted in that way which is
nice i feel that that is what that
translates into the film you know nanu
our cinematographer like what she did is
you know she films the majority of it on
and so there was there's something so
raw about the way that she works and her
and francis together so and i feel like
you feel that in in in the movie this
sort of and also
sorry no you go yeah no it's good
unpolished oh yeah
it's not like pretentious in that way
yeah it's not like this is completely
perfect and here we go yeah and also i
think it depends for actors who's
looking at you through the lens and
because
nano's i mean she's brilliant
cinematographer but she's also like this
gorgeous person yeah she's so you feel
that she's loving what the actors are
doing and i feel like there's a kind of
thing a circle kind of happening with
that as well she takes her time to light
everything and really so it's precise
but then it gives us the freedom to
do our thing yeah incredibly effective
choice organic was the right word to use
because i feel like sometimes with a
period piece where it feels like a
little more rigid and inaccessible yeah
but then you use that kind of technique
and i feel like they get more access to
the characters yeah makes it feel like
more like real almost like you're more
involved in like the kind of gritty
reality of what their lives were really
like
like through the camera book yeah in a
way sorry yeah but it was yeah it just
felt like the times where you did do um
still you know um
that's static thank you that was like
still shots
static shots it was for a specific
reason there was a specific reason for
that stillness and the rest of the time
it's shaky and we're there so that i
think that that is way more meaningful
visually to have that to make that
choice between those two energies and
when it did go still like when we did
the mask scene like once the mask is on
and it goes really still it kind of adds
like so much more of a dramatic effect
to everything and it makes it even more
eerie because you're like oh
everything's everything's changed i'm
different exactly yeah i want to keep
you here all day that won't let me
i have so many more questions but huge
huge huge congratulations on your films
very very powerful you're all
exceptional in it and i cannot wait to
see more work from you behind the lens
to everybody out there thank you keep an
eye out for emily thank you for watching
this tift 2022 interview we will be back
with more soon
you